wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
und wie fandest du die ausstellung das
stadtschloss war beeindruckend warum die
ausstellung war relativ uninteressant
discount vier stunden hier und ist nicht
früher als danach eine ausbildung machen
wie lange bleibst du eigentlich nicht
lange ich lebe gerade herum und doch
nicht gründlich besuchen und sage group
ag jetzt schön das ist sie wieder besser
geht ich bin mir ist in meinem vater
sehr jahre
er wollte mal dass ich die welt sehe und
jetzt mache ich
danke für die letzten wochen
so froh dass du da warst was haben wir
uns jetzt da es gibt kein kleines museum
das die richtung gefällt ein bekannter
komponist aus dieser stadt hat dort
gelebt er schrieb viele stücke für geige
und klavier und er ist vor ein paar
jahren gestorben ich bin noch nie da
sahen wir uns das mal anschauen
[Musik]